good morning everyone I am just
ridiculously excited to be here
um and by here I mean sadly here in
California uh I I'm coming to you from
the other side of the planet I I think
at this point uh uh but for folks who
don't know me I'm Chandler crew that
work at Google uh I'm one of our
technical leads working on programming
languages I spent a lot of time working
on C plus plus and compilers and lvm and
optimization
uh and and I'm here to talk a little bit
about C plus plus and maybe what comes
next uh versus plus but I just have to
start off because I I'm actually really
delighted to be able to be here at all I
I sadly wasn't able to travel uh uh but
talking to the organizers of NDC Tech
Town they're they're just amazing they
were able to uh put together a virtual
presentation and so I'm able to come to
you from from the other side of the
planet as maybe the uh easiest 9 A.M
talk I've ever had to wake up for uh
because it's midnight here
um but that actually means you get me
kind of in my Prime I'm kind of a night
owl and so this this works well for me
in the end uh
um I really wish I could be there though
uh even if it were in the morning I
really missed the energy of an in-person
conference so I'm going to try and I'm
going to try and imagine that I'm there
that we've got the whole big audience
thing going uh and and I really
appreciate you guys being here so that I
can talk to you because this is a talk
that I did give at supersports North but
that's that's not in Europe and I I was
really sad a lot of people I know
couldn't make it and it's something that
I really really want to talk with
everyone in the C plus Community about
and and I was just so excited to have
the opportunity to kind of
come to this particular audience get to
share it with this audience and get to
kind of get more people to to hear what
we're talking about hear what their
feedback is and and start a real
discussion with you all and so I you
know thank you to all of the audience
and thank you to the organizers for
making this happen I'm I wouldn't have
imagined this was possible
um I also am going to try and go fairly
quickly through the talk uh because I
want to give as much time as I can for
for kind of q a uh they have a
microphone I can hear you it should be
pretty easy to actually have a proper q
a even with the virtual talk
um
and so but apologies if I'm going a
little bit fast if you do need to like
interrupt me you know uh get a question
and flag down the person with the
microphone I'm happy to pause and try
and clarify anything but unless it's a
clarification let's hold the questions
for the end you know write it down you
know text it to yourself or something
and we'll we'll grab it at the end
and so with that let's let's just dive
in uh
Plus
what comes next
and and the answer to this is a little
surprising
I don't know what comes next
uh I really don't this is this is
actually the answer uh yeah I hope you
weren't expecting a different talk I
don't actually have an answer at the end
of The Talk
but I think this is a really important
question that we need to answer
uh and so I want to start digging into
this question a little bit and first we
need to understand what it means for a
language to come next let's let's look
at C going into C plus right C plus plus
came after C added a tremendous amount
of functionality there are other
examples we can look at
typescript which came after JavaScript
we can look at Swift came after
Objective C kotlin came after Java
but when we look at C plus plus
there's a real blank here there is a
good there isn't this good language that
I feel like comes naturally after C plus
plus and I think we need to really
figure out what might fit into this uh I
don't think we're at the end of that
journey I don't think we've got an
answer that we can plug in here so where
do we begin answering this question if I
don't know yet where do we start well I
always want to start with the goals
right I want to start with what problem
I'm trying to solve so what are our
goals for C plus plus so what problem
what what programming or software
development problem do we use C plus
plus
to solve
Titus and myself Paris Winters and I I
gave a long talk really digging into
this uh two years ago at cppcon where we
really tried to talk about what is C
plus plus right what problems do we want
it to solve uh have fun watching the
talk if you want it's a super fun talk
we had lots of fun uh making it coming
up with different ways to get at get at
this idea of what is c plus
we also wrote a paper uh as part of the
committee process it really laid out
what our goals were for C plus plus
right we want performance critical
software we need that software in the
language it's written in to be able to
evolve we need our code to be easy to
read understand to easy to write we want
practical safety and testing we need
fast and scalable development processes
and platforms we need we need to be able
to support modern operating systems
Hardware architectures environments
right this is this is what we want out
of C plus
and and that really gets to the the
heart of this question because at the
moment C plus plus fall short of these
goals it really is a part we want it to
be
um lots of you in the room can probably
think of something that you would like
to improve about C plus plus that if you
just had a magic wand you know my
presentation about rewind was like I
will make C plus plus better right
um and this part is incredibly difficult
right but why is C plus plus falling
behind our goals there's a huge amount
of effort being invested into it we've
worked on it uh for a long time with
lots of people across the industry have
so understanding the why I think is
really challenging and and maybe even
more important than thinking about
specific improvements or specific areas
where C plus plus could be doing better
why is it struggling
that there are two core reasons here
first C plus plus has accumulated
Decades of technical debt and and this
is it for bad reasons it's not like
someone made a mistake here that's not
what happened at all uh This was done
often for the best possible reasons as
an example a huge part of C plus plus is
Success was building directly on top of
the existing SP ecosystem right this
gave it access to the dominant software
ecosystem at the time it allowed it to
to be incredibly more useful to people
but it also meant inheriting the C3
processor textual inclusion C headers
strange integer promotion semantics I
mean a whole list of things inheriting a
lot of C's technical debt now this this
is a really well motivated decision it
was it was an excellent reason to do
this but it had a very high cost right
and all of the technical debt C plus
plus has has a very high cost
and it's compounded by the second reason
which is prioritizing backwards
compatibility
and again prioritizing backwards
compatibility isn't in and of itself a
bad thing it can be really useful and a
huge feature for a lot of people
but it does create a problem because it
means that every time we make a mistake
in the language
we can't fix it we can't even fix easy
mistakes we can't fix them even when
they are new and it would be relatively
cheap to do so because we want to have
that backwards compatibility we also
can't fix it when we have tools that can
manage the cost to fixing it for
Developers
we distort new features that we're
adding to the language to avoid breaking
any Legacy code we have color weight and
co-yield and co-return and I don't know
what the next code keyword will be but
there will be one and it's all to try
and deal with backwards compatibility
right every time we do this we basically
take on an ever-growing set of
acceptably small increments of technical
debt
on top of the inherited pile of
technical debt
but backwards compatibility does more
than that uh it it also prevents fixing
technical debt
because by Nature if you have technical
debt uh and you have shy of the law
which says that you know whether you
intended it or not code will depend on
every single feature of your
implementation
that means codes depending on this
technical debt someone's holding down
their space bar to warm up their
keyboard or something right you you
can't just fix technical debt while
maintaining backwards compatibility
these are these are fundamental tensions
right
um in fact some of the time backwards
compatibility is why we took on the
technical debt in the first place uh and
so this this is a really
self-reinforcing system
there is another thing that makes it
difficult to improve C plus plus though
uh which is that the the evolution
process itself makes improvements
extremely difficult
simple plus is evolved as part of the
standards committee and this uses a
multi-year waterfall committee process
access is is restricted and expensive
you you have to attend in person in many
cases in order to have a voice uh
decisions are made by a live vote of
those who happen to be in the room
um
and a lot of the process a lot of the
aspects of this they are it's not like
the people running the committee are
unaware of the challenges a lot of this
process comes from ISO uh and and it's
it's not really in our control right
it's not even in the control of all any
of the programming languages that are
part of iso and fundamentally iso's
process has it has a reason behind it it
is oriented around ensuring that you
know Nations and and experts especially
those companies have a voice and are
represented in discussions and decisions
around standards and I mean I think
that's that's actually okay right the
the that's a valid set of priorities but
it's a very different set of priorities
from the ones that I wouldn't choose in
order to build kind of an effective
group for designing an incredibly
complex Software System right it doesn't
prioritize things like being inclusive
and welcoming or being a very high
productive uh very effective team to
tackle these complex design challenges
and so I think this this compounds the
other problems right the process itself
just compounds all these other problems
and I think you see some of this
reflected in the design right we we tend
to prioritize safe easy changes to make
rather than difficult maybe expensive
changes to make that have higher impact
that might allow us to start paying down
this technical debt and that's that's
just a function of how the process works
but okay that's enough doom and glue
what what options are there like what is
next like where do we actually go from
here right uh especially if improving C
plus plus directly is is is
difficult enough that it it's not
proving a really effective path
I think the obvious answer for what
options we have are existing programming
languages that would be ideal uh
programming languages are are wildly
expensive uh especially factoring in the
larger ecosystem around them and so this
is where we we absolutely should start
um a bunch of uh existing programming
languages are fantastic but are garbage
collected and honestly garbage collected
languages are pretty awesome I don't
know how many folks have used them
they're amazing because they really
simplify the programming model they can
be really simple reliable safe easy to
use they're fantastic right
um
the challenge is that they they have
performance gaps right they still have
some performance Gap maybe they have a
performance gap on throughput maybe on
latency uh that there's a huge body of
research trying to find better ways to
minimize the performance Gap but at the
end of the day
they do have a cost right they really do
have a Costas they don't often serve in
the roles that we're looking to use C
plus right when we look at that priority
list right performance was at the very
top
foreign
candidate that we should be thinking
about rust I
now this is an arrest talk I hate to
tell anyone who is thinking this is a
rust talk that's not anything to do with
Russ though because frankly Russ is
amazing if if rust works you should
absolutely use it uh it's a fantastic
language I'm super excited to see what
they're doing in the community I I am
really impressed by both the language
and the community you're doing an
amazing amazing job you know so if Russ
is working please don't get distracted
by by this talk at all this isn't this
isn't for you right
but there is a problem for some folks in
using rest
and that's that moving a C plus plus
ecosystem especially a large one to rest
is very difficult it's very very
difficult and it's very very expensive
uh you know some of my colleagues are
actually working on figuring out ways to
try and make this easier to make it a
little bit more uh possible a little bit
more uh feasible but it's it's still
early days and right now the cost is
just really difficult uh really
difficult for a lot of groups to swallow
okay
so I don't know of any other existing
languages that are really great options
here there are of course many other
languages I could spend a whole talk
trying to like go through every single
language but none of them seem to really
work and so I think it's useful to kind
of look at what approaches have worked
in the past so let's go back to my my
little list here we have C to C plus
plus you work really great the Java to
typescript like crypto typescript sorry
uh it works really great and these These
are kind of interestingly similar in one
respect both of these
are taking basically a superset approach
right uh C plus and typescript are
supersets of c and JavaScript
perspective book and this is a really
effective way to kind of take an
existing ecosystem and extend it right
but we also see some different patterns
emerging here over time so objective to
the Swift is different it's a more
advanced kind of evolutionary path
because Swift has a totally new syntax
it's not it's not a superset of
objective-c syntax at all and instead it
uses compiler technology to provide this
interoperability to provide the path
from objective-c into Swift
and I think we see it even more clearly
if we look at at kotlin which is a very
new language but that's uh in a lot of
ways trying to build on top of the Java
ecosystem
and and I think kotlin is is a fantastic
example of this idea that instead of
following a superset
um particularly a syntactic superset
approach
really leveraging uh interoperability
and and bi-directional interoperability
where you can Java code can call kotlin
code and column code can call Java code
the ergonomics are good they don't feel
like you know completely unrelated
programming languages they have you know
the same core constructs beneath them
and this makes a very compelling
adoption path a very compelling uh
tool-assisted migration path
but it does so with the ability to make
pretty significant and dramatic
improvements to the language which can
be really difficult with a superset
when we look at all of these like when
we look at all of these we start to see
a pattern emerging
each and every one of these was designed
for the purpose they're designed
to be a successor language
okay
and I think this is really exciting so
so a successor language here is one to
build on an existing ecosystem without
bootstrapping a new one it gives you
bi-directional interoperability
you know some optimized learning curve
you can just adopt it pretty easily and
ideally you can migrate code with tools
not just manually but actually with
tools migrate code from the old language
to the new language
we see this uh with with Swift and we
see it really compellingly with kotlin
this isn't like a new idea either if you
actually watch curbs bridge to new thing
and talk you'll see him talking about
exactly these different kinds of
successor language approaches both the
superset and this more interoperability
based form
but for me I'm really interested in in
how we could do something really
dramatically improve C plus plus and do
it through this interoperability
successor language approach and so this
is what a group of us have been working
on for a couple of years uh we've just
made it public uh this year called it's
called the carbon language and this is
basically an experimental successor to C
plus
so Carmen where do we start with carbon
we start at the same place we start with
C plus plus we start with goals right
cargo's goals is a successor language
start off with the same six goals as C
plus plus
but we add one more goal here that's
really critical to make carbon a
successor language
interoperability width and migration
from existing C plus code
and there are three parts of these goals
that are going to be key to be a
successful successor language here
interoperability migration and language
evolution
the interoperability we don't have to
inherit all of the C plus plus technical
debt this is this is what separates us
from a superset approach and it allows
us to really dramatically start pushing
down the technical debt
migration allows us to provide immediate
and dramatic improvements to code right
and then language evolution is how we
sustain this how we actually keep this
kind of improvement going forward so
without this we're going to get a single
step function Improvement and then we're
done and I don't think that that makes
any sense we're going to go through the
cost of this we have to have some path
to continually actually refresh the
language keep it keep it really really
effective keep it meeting developers
needs even as they change even as our
technology changes
foreign with the three of these I think
we have something pretty exciting and
this is this is basically our path to
avoid to avoiding backwards
compatibility the way C plus plus does
is to try and use tools to do these
upgrades to do this improvement over
time
all right so let's talk about the
language itself I'm just going to try
and introduce you to a few pieces of the
language uh based on time I may have to
uh skim through a little bit but we can
go back and dig into this in more detail
if it's useful let's go in and just look
at a few things one thing just as a
reminder right the carbon is is still in
its infancy uh we really wanted to make
this an open source project uh very very
early in the project so we could get
broad input and a lot of people involved
early on we're incredibly far away from
being done none of this is is baked or
set in stone we've got we've got a long
long road ahead of us uh and so I don't
want you to get over indexed on this but
I do want to kind of introduce some of
the concepts we think we can bring into
the language to make something that's
going to be more powerful and more and
more uh appealing for developers so
let's start off
with the simple things and start off
with syntax and one of the improvements
we'd like to bring in are introducer
keywords and a very simple parsing
grammar something that makes the syntax
incredibly obvious incredibly easy to
parse easy to build new tools on top of
but unfortunately this is kind of the
the
greatest breaking change of them all
doing this you know requires that you're
doing something like a tooling based
process but it also turns out this is
where tools are best right tools are
really really good at doing these kinds
of upgrades these kinds of migrations
and the way this looks uh if we start
looking at some code Snippets is when we
declare a new function we add a little
uh F in keyword at the start of it and
that tells us our declarative function
right uh when we're declaring a variable
if my slide updates
eventually
there we go uh including a variable we
get a VAR keyword in there just to just
to try and make sure it's very clear as
this variable declaration we even do
little things because we also want to
use name and then a colon followed by a
type
because this solves some of the hardest
parsing problems one of the things that
I find most frustrating is you should go
to Wikipedia there's an article the most
vexing parse
it doesn't mention the sequence plus the
most vexing parts and it's a C plus plus
example and that just makes me really
sad uh and it's actually this thing it's
it's variable declarations in C plus I
end up hitting the most vexing Parts in
that we don't need to have vexing parses
we can have easy parses for humans for
compilers for Ides for you know Vim for
emacs for every code editor in the world
right we can make this super super easy
let's talk about some other changes here
another big change is trying to have a
really well designed way to have
function input parameters or basically
read-only values these are values that
you're just reading you're not going to
try and modify them they're immutable
they don't change anywhere because this
turns out to be an overwhelming chunk of
the the code you write simple plus tends
to use const references for these
are kind of good for functional inputs
except when that's actually a
performance overhead because they would
fit and register right using a constant
reference for an INT is really
unfortunate
um and that means you kind of have to
know for each and every type well how do
I want to pass it as an input it gets
worse because when you're writing a
template code you don't know what type
you had so you just have to take it as a
constant reference even when that's a
performance overhead but fixing this is
an incredibly disruptive breaking change
it's also a huge opportunity for us
so what does this end up looking like
you have in your parameters you say that
I want a circle right this is a
parameter named Circle it has the circle
type and this is an input parameter the
default is an input parameter because we
think that's that's the default for
functions
right we have a 32-bit integer input
parameter
right and it just works works really
efficiently and the compiler the
implementation is responsible for
figuring out what's the most efficient
way to pass these parameters right we've
got to really optimize that really
nicely for you
but if we have these input parameters
that's nice we have these values and we
use those for for these read-only uh
things we do need to do mutation
it turns out programs aren't as
interesting without mutation uh at least
for me I I don't think I'm good enough
to really do the the pure functional
programming it's it's never been
something I can I can wrap my head
around easily
um so we want to have mutation right and
the way we do that is through pointers
pointers give us both indirect access to
objects and mutation
um and our whole hope is to try and
compress all of that space into a simple
construct of pointers when you compare
them to references pointers are a lot
simpler because with references you
can't you can't really talk about the
reference separately from the the
referenced object right you have two
things but you can only talk to one of
them and pointers give you a very
natural way of of representing that a
lot of languages that have references uh
modern languages that have references
they actually very explicitly model them
as pointers
um and and use something like automatic
dereckencing because it's so important
to be able to separate the two pieces of
this we want to try and preserve that
separation and not have 14 different
kinds of references either I'm going to
try and have all of them just be
pointers let's head pointers come with
their own problems which we can fix we
can make pointers always not no we can
make you know use some other dedicated
tool for things like pointer arithmetic
and indexing that can be a separate tool
that has the guard rails you probably
want built into it and that leaves
pointers kind of in this very simple
very easy to understand space
and in code this looks like you know we
have an output parameter results here
our input output parameter results here
and that's just pass by pointer and for
me I really like this because when you
have an NL parameter like this in some
ways it is indirect right you're
modifying the caller's vector it's not
yours and we make that very explicit we
have a pointer to the colors vector and
then in the code we actually go and
modify it and so it's very clear this is
this is actually modifying the colors uh
vector
another big change
is to try and simplify how we name types
especially complicated types this is
particularly important in generic code
and in meta programming where we have
parameterized type names in interesting
ways in C plus plus they're kind of two
separate grammars that
kind of overlap somewhat but also
conflict in various places results in a
bunch of complexity and parsing a bunch
of complexity in the language
and we try to take a simplifying idea uh
what if we just say that no look when
you try to name a type that's an
expression it uses the same grammar
you're just naming a compile you're just
writing an expression that expands to a
type
uh one of the the consequences is that
we already have a nice balanced
delimiters for passing parameters to
types we have parentheses
and so here you can see we have a circle
this is this is actually an expression
right it references an identifier the
the Class Type declared earlier
um i-32 is also an expression uh similar
to well 32 right similar to an integer
literal you can have an integer type
literal that gives you a 32-bit type
and we have you know the more
interesting case of vector uh which is a
parameterized type and we use normal
function style parameters to pass uh 30
to the floating Point type as a type
parameter here
another thing we've tried to simplify is
the root namespace uh so we have uh
instead of having a single Global
namespace for all code everywhere try to
have packages which are kind of the the
rough unit of code that would typically
be versioned together or distributed
together
um have its own uh route as an in a
namespace and all the packages have to
be named and this way there isn't a
single pump level namespace every top
level namespace it's actually local to
something something you probably control
and it's kind of version together and
controlled together and it's given a
name for whenever someone else needs to
access it
the way this works in code is you start
off all of your code saying that hey I'm
in this geometry package here
and then when you want to go and import
an API now that you have that name you
don't have to textually include the code
you can actually just write import
and import the Mac package
and when you want to use it you say math
dot PI right and the fact that math is
in the namespace isn't surprising
because you wrote that locally right uh
and the fact that you get to Pi is
unsurprising because you do that inside
of math so there's nothing you know from
outside of your package that can ever
come in and add things to your packages
name so it's your package controls its
namespace very very directly
foreign
and so so we also made some changes to
how members are declared uh they're
public by default so I'm just going to
zip through this a little bit
uh one thing I do want to try and make
clear is we we have just canonicalized
on using an explicit object parameter to
declare a method
and so we have you know non-methods or
like a static member function doesn't
have an object parameter here at all and
when we want a method we add an object
parameter uh you use a keyword to
identify it I use me here the use of me
here is really weird basically every
other language even including C plus
plus now that it's getting explicit
object parameters calls itself uh we're
probably going to change this to also
call itself but you know when we started
off we were trying to save two
characters probably not worth it but you
have a keyword that says this is the
object parameter and you have a special
type for it to kind of model how that
parameter works and this means that this
is a method
and because it's an input parameter it's
a read-only method it can't modify the
object that you're calling it on
but you just call it like normally you
have an article you say as HTML
and then we also have mutating methods
but those need to accept pointers right
so we have to take the the object by
pointer because we're going to mutate it
right
and we have a special tool called Adder
that just says look to this method you
need to take the address of the object
before you pass it to us because this is
one importance that if we if we only use
pointers this would be way too
inconvenient to to write code and so
this is the big escape hatch that we use
here to just cause you to take the
address automatically so as a
consequence you can also just write
article.publish looks just like it would
in C plus plus but it's very explicit
this is a mutation and how that mutation
works
uh we do have single inheritance
um and classes are default we have some
nice Syntax for that but it's really
unsurprising so I'm just going to zip
right through this lots of nice keywords
uh we also have keywords for abstract
methods and keywords instead of override
we've tried to just canonicalize on the
same set of keywords and make them very
clear and in the same position
everywhere
sorry to skip forward but I want to make
sure that we get to get through
everything in time
the last real language topic I want to
mention is we have powerful definition
checked generics and I think this may be
the the biggest change that we need to
bring into carbon from C plus but I
think in some ways that's also one of
the most foundational changes we need to
make because today C plus plus uses
templates to do all generic programming
uh let's do static polymorphism very
nice low you know low coupling ways of
dealing with multiple interfaces it's a
great in some ways generic programming
is fantastic but using templates has a
lot of drawbacks uh they're duct typed
uh and they're light bound right it
means that you can't really type check
the template definitions even with uh C
plus plus Concepts that we have that we
got in in C plus plus 20 you can
constrain the template but you can't
fully definition check it it only
partially addresses it and I think it
doesn't really go to the important last
step of fundamentally checking the
generics fully uh at their definition
time for example we can't build Dynamic
type Erasure on top of the the C plus
plus uh 20 Concepts we got so we want to
add definition generics very similar to
to C plus plus Ox Concepts but maybe
even more similar to to more modern
programming languages like rests traits
uh and Swift protocols which are also
which are both lots of definition
generics
and this directly addresses a ton of
issues with the template system however
it's particularly challenging for carbon
because we can't just add definition
check to generics we have to
interoperate with C plus that means we
have definition generics that you can
extend to templates
and so we fully support C plus plus
templates within this framework
but with a very smooth Evolution path to
adopt definition checking for your
generic code where you want to
I I could spend like the whole talk
talking about this I'm going to give
just a very briefest of introduction
here
uh to start off with we have to define
the interface that we want to be generic
over right and this is called maybe
unsurprisingly interface
um this interface is named summary it
has a method summarize the summarize
returns a string nothing too nothing too
surprising
and then we can write a generic function
right and this generic function print
summary uh you know it takes a type
parameter and this is a carbon the
square brackets here are carbons deduced
parameter syntax and so this is a
deduced type parameter you cannot pass
it explicitly and because of that
exclamation point it is a generic
parameter it is actually something that
has to be done at compile time not at
runtime
and we say that this is a summary type
not just any type but a summary type and
that uses the interface above
once we do this
oh
we have you know this nice
generic and we could do some some really
really cool things here right we have
our we have our X we pass it with t this
is where we deduce that parameter from
and now we can call x dot summarize and
we can type check this
when we see the definition we never need
to see the type that implements summary
because the summary interface tells us
exactly how to type check this I mean so
this gives us a fully type checked
definition of a generic function
and when you want to implement an
interface types do that explicitly it's
not automatic the way it is in C plus
plus templates you have to actually say
I want to implement summary interface
okay and so if we have say a news
article right
we can Implement summary with this
declaration but hey look I want to
implement my class as a summary type
okay and now I have to Define that
summarize method
and because this is part of of the news
article this is also a method on news
article right we put it inside of this
impul block so that it could be used for
the generics mechanism but it's still a
method on news article so down here
right I have a function that takes a
news article uh right and I can both use
that with my generic function because it
has this impulse summary and also
directly call it
makes sense hopefully I know I'm going a
little bit fast
uh the the last thing that interfaces
provide us is a single language
extension Point mechanism for API design
so instead of using ADL uh and and
having some real complexities with
overload sets and ADL we have a much
more clearly designed and clearly
defined extension Point mechanism in the
language we use it for generics and we
use it for everything else that we can
so that we just push all of that work
right into this piece of the the
language
so let's imagine we have some other
package of code right someone else's
codes it's not our code this is another
package
and we want to implement the summary
interface
we can actually do that we have to we
have to say that this isn't uh an
internal impul we can't change the API
of the other package this is something
that's external to it
all right and so we say external input
say that that's this other package.tweet
because similar to a news article you
can summarize a tweet
bit redundant but we could do that
right and once you implement the
summarize summary for this Tweet now I
can come down into this function I take
a tweet and I can call my generic
function on it
and the reason that I'm allowed to do
this is because this is the code that
defines the interface summary
so there are two places where you can
Define these implementations you can
Define them with type and you can Define
them with the interface
we only Define them in those two places
and a nice property is that because
those are the only two places you can
Define it we can actually check that you
have a definition we don't have any no
diagnostic required here we have a
definitive check that like yes you
implemented summary for this time we
found it there is exactly one no other
would be possible there's no link time
problem there's no runtime problem here
that's right so we got something that's
a lot more principle and a lot easier to
work with for programmers
okay I can keep going for a long time
but I need to spend at least a little
bit of time talking about one thing that
we can't really skip over here
interrupt all this is nice programming
language design the key to carbon is C
plus plus interop
what does this look like well we have to
start with some C plus plus code so it's
boring right we've got a struct circle
in C plus plus
the magic happens in carbon because in
carbon I can import from C plus plus
code
okay
and what this is going to do is it's
going to fire up your C plus compiler
clang in this case uh it's going to go
and it's gonna parse
uh this C plus plus header uh the
circle.h and it's going to turn it into
a clang header module right implicitly
and automatically and it's going to
import that as if it were a module as if
it were part of carbon itself right
and then it's going to give you access
to this simple plus code from within
carbon so now I can talk about that c
plus type Circle
all right I can
I can pass it to a carbon generic here
right and and carbon's generic or
template is going to have to work with C
plus plus types I can
run it through a for loop I can access
members and I can do math on them all of
the things that you would expect to be
able to do with your C plus plus type
you can just do directly in carbon when
we do this by kind of compiler level
interoperability that we build into the
language
but that's only one direction and we
really need bi-directional
interoperability so we can go back to C
plus plus code
and in C plus plus code we can include a
header file and this isn't you know this
is a header file that you write this is
something that's provided by carbon and
we can extend clang to under the hood go
and take this carbon library that we
wrote on the left here and turn it into
a C plus plus car playing header module
that it can import into your C plus code
it's going to transform all the things
and give you access to it so now the
geometry package and carbon becomes a
namespace in C plus and my print area
function is just a function and I can
call it from carbon I can pass my Vector
of circles to it and it'll trigger all
the implicit conversions and turn it
into a carbon slice and then pass it
through right The Whole Bowl is make
this just work
so that's kind of how we expect to get
interrupted
let's talk about interoperability
migration we also need to cover process
so how is carbon the project going to
actually evolve over time successfully
first and for me foremost is culture
right the community and the culture
there's a great quote from Peter Drucker
culture eats strategy for breakfast
technology for lunch and products for
dinner and soon thereafter everything
else too right uh this is a quote that's
going on a whole the rounds of like a
business world and all that that's where
I encountered it but I think it's
actually really true for technology
projects and for teams as well I really
really love this and so we're
prioritizing culture really highly in
carbon we want to try and have an
inclusive welcoming community
we want to have a friendly and
approachable Community we have a very
strong comprehensive code of conduct we
have an open
process for governance and for changing
carbon we make decisions with a clear
rationale especially for their very
difficult trade-offs when they're
challenging things for us to consider we
work super hard on this
we also want to make sure that the
project can have you know the batteries
included tools and ecosystem that
programmers expect we don't want to just
ship you you know a language design or a
language specification we want to ship
you a compiler and a standard library
and a user guide and some tooling and
some migration tools and update tools
and you know a linter maybe and yes a
package manager
but but we're getting ahead of ourselves
eventually eventually we want to be able
to have this
but from the Project's perspective we're
setting ourselves up to have a very wide
open scope we don't want to narrow
ourselves down we want to be able to
tackle these things in the in the in the
future
once we're ready it's going to be a
while we're nowhere ready yet we don't
we actually don't even have a working
compiler yet I'm going to come back to
that
I also want to try and follow modern
open source development model uh this uh
we hope looks really familiar to people
makes it really easy for them to get
involved contribute things to make
carbon better you know in little ways
and in big ways uh we use lldm's kind of
Open Source licensing model we use a
contributor license agreement to make
sure we can fix bugs in it we'll use
GitHub we have a real-time chat on
Discord we use Google Docs and Google
meetings and sometimes zoom and
sometimes other things to try and
collaborate one thing you'll notice is
we use a lot of technology and a lot of
tools to try and collaborate better we
don't try and stick to some kind of
Common Core set of tools we want to use
everything we can to try and make the
process better try and make the project
more effective
um
we also need to have like an actual
process for evolving right we need some
process for improving it but we've
distilled this down
to pull requests get help pull requests
that's it
that's the total Improvement model
there's nothing more required we'll use
pull requests for design improvements
for specification for adding
documentation for implementing things
all of it
um even significant language designs are
developed in pull requests all we do is
we add kind of a proposal document to
the pull request that spells out the
interesting content the interesting
context you know why we're making a
change why it's important all the
Alternatives that we've considered right
and once we have a pull request we can
just use code review and code review
like processes two actually you know
affect this who approves all this poor
requests well we have a governance
system for that
and so the governance system is again
really simple uh by and large governance
is done through code reviews but if we
have if we have a question if there's a
critical decision we need to make
ultimately we have a three-person group
of leads that are responsible for making
decisions it's kind of like you know the
benevolent dictator for Life model but
you know scaled up not a dictator not
for life
but we're going to keep the benevolent
part that part's good uh
but we don't want to scale it up too
much right if we get back to a committee
it's not going to be any more efficient
it's going to have all of the problems
that that we really have with with C
plus Evolution so we keep it super small
it's just three people uh myself uh Kate
Gregory who's actually I think hiding in
the back row of the talk if you want to
pester her and and Richard Smith are the
three current leads and we're even
hoping to over time have this group of
leads rotate uh uh this shouldn't be
something that only only three people
can do we want to have a decent number
of people in the project who can take on
the the responsibility of being a lead
and making decisions but then you know
after a year or two you know take that
hat off relax a bit you know take take a
break from that and do do others part do
other things within the project we also
want to try and make sure that we keep
it as representative as possible we're
going to try and make sure we don't have
you know more than one person from any
one organization long term but we need
the project to grow a bit before we can
get to that
so so all this is kind of you know our
core governance uh we have lots of plans
going forward
um I'll just briefly mention kind of
where carbon is at today uh we have we
actually have a bunch of contributors to
carbon
um already and this slide is actually
out of date this was from July before we
actually made it public uh uh but like
if I regenerate it you can't read
anything we've we've got like another 10
plus people who who have been helping us
out the open source project
you know our current uh focus in roadmap
was going public trying to complete the
the core language design and trying to
get a demo implementation of that core
language design uh speaking of demo
implementations uh
what's our demo implementation I said we
don't have a real compiler what we have
is something else we have is a uh
something that's not an implementation
but kind of like uh it's a way it's an
interpreter that you can kind of put
code into and you can see how it would
behave if you ran it through if you
actually executed that code it's an
abstract interpreter that just models
the semantics of carbons of the carbon
language and and one of the people
that's been helping out on carbon is
actually Matt godbolt and so when we
were looking at the design of this we
actually realized that it resembles
something that we're probably all
familiar with compiler Explorer and we
actually call this the carbon Explorer
now uh with his with his encouragement
um and so so this basically lets us
explore what carbon code would look like
understand the semantics and and it's
also designed to be really easy to
prototype things really easy to extend
and play with new features uh and so
that's kind of our platform that we're
exploring the implementation in right
now
uh and I will briefly see if we can get
a live demo to actually work here
hopefully you all can see so if you go
to you know
carbon.compilerexplorer.com it's live
you can you can go there you can find
this example
right if I if I remove my X here right
I'm going to get a compilation error
because it
I don't have good syntax I can add the X
back
uh I had more time I happen to do lots
more kind of demos uh one thing that
you'll see here on the right hand side
it is an assembly because this is this
is this you know interpreter and so what
you'll see once you get past all the
code Snippets
there's a lot of code Snippets
here we go what you'll start to see here
is uh an actual log of the compiler
Explorer implementing carbon And So It
Begins type checking everything and it
begins you know processing uh
declarations and type checking those and
you can go through the the different
steps as it walks through every single
step of evaluating each compile time
expression that names each type that's
part of the type Checker right you can
watch each and every step of the
semantics actually get implemented in
the Explorer which is super super nice
for understanding very subtle details of
how the language semantics work it's
really cool feel free to check it out
and explore it it's it's it's a fun
little project uh and it gives us a
really great way to understand carbon
and understand how it works
foreign
but
we haven't actually answered our
question
what comes next for C plus plus well I
still don't know right C plus plus is
probably a big part of what comes next
for C plus plus uh a lot of users
genuinely need backwards compatibility
and there are a lot of good reasons to
keep trying to improve C plus plus I
don't want anyone to stop doing that
we also should probably be using garbage
collected languages more often they're
great programming environments for
people so so if you can you should use
them and if you could use restitution to
use rust that's fantastic
so the real question for me is is you
know is carbon a part of what comes next
for C plus plus
and I don't even know the answer to this
I I don't think I can answer this I
actually need all of you I need all the
sequence plus Community to come and help
us answer this right and so so this talk
and really the whole carbon project is
our whole goal is to together find out
whether something like carbon a
programming language like carbon is a
part of what comes next for C plus plus
uh I hope that you're interested I I try
to go to go through this as fast as I
can uh but if hopefully we can do at
least a few questions uh and and I
really hope to see you all of you on the
Discord and maybe or at least like going
through the GitHub trying things out
giving us feedback and and keeping an
eye on the project because you know
we've still got a long road to walk here
we're just getting started with the
design we're just getting started with
this Explorer we're gonna have years of
work in front of us just to explore this
experiment understand whether this is
something that makes sense
and thank you again for having me all
the way over in Norway
[Applause]
questions
one of the things
fantastic uh one lesson picture I think
that I'm missing in typical across is
destructive moves among us and uh yes
I've been told so probably never have
but if that's something you could have
it's a great question I so the question
is can we have destructive move
semantics and I think the answer is
mostly yes
but it is really hard and and the reason
it's really hard is because of C plus
plus right the the people who are saying
we can't get it on the C plus plus I
think they have a point it's it's really
difficult to graft destructive move
semantics onto C plus plus uh there's
also some some other subtle details here
but we this is actually part of carbon
that is designed uh if you go in and
search on on car and carbon's design
docs for um uh there's a proposal about
unformed objects and initialization and
it talks about the idea of destructive
move and and how we're hoping to kind of
get the best balance we can between
destructive moves like you have in Rust
and and where C plus plus is coming from
what about reflection
what about reflection great question
um I would love for us to do good
reflection and and and we're trying to
set ourselves up for this uh using
Expressions as the core grammar for
talking about types
kind of kind of sets you up to do things
like all methods on type objects and do
very reflectiony kinds of things with an
incredibly natural syntax uh and so so
I'm hoping that we're set up very
effectively for this something we're
thinking a lot about however we've got
to walk before we run we've got it we've
got a or I don't know what the right
analogy is here we're we're like we've
gotta like gotta like have cell division
before we can build like an organized
life form with like intelligence and
start reflecting on it we're way earlier
stages and so as we get the core
language in place we're hoping we're
leaving good kind of Foundations to
build reflection on but actually
building reflection and building meta
programming I think is something that
we're going to have to invest in in the
future
my main interest in reflection is
messaging and uh there's a lot of thing
about reflection like uh calling
internal uh calling internal uh function
etc etc which isn't that interesting but
when it comes where I really miss uh
reflection is messaging being able to
send uh struct
of some kind to to another place
yes
I actually think this is not reflection
I think that uh having some kind of
serializable and deserializable way to
work with data structures it's something
that should be baked directly into the
language you shouldn't need even
reflection for that we should have a
first class feature in the programming
language designed around uh how to kind
of move data around when you don't have
kind of a you know a single address
space with a single ABI and everything
in memory and no no threads or anything
like that but when you have the more
complex cases uh and so actually we're
hoping to add that as kind of a core
language feature for carbon uh the the
kind of directly addresses those use
cases
but again
early stages we this is like an idea in
someone's head so I don't think we've
we've actually gotten it implemented yet
uh hello so I'm curious how how would
you maintain interoperability with the C
plus plus at assets
continues to evolve in SQL space 23 26
Etc
on and on yes uh so how do we how do we
how do we interoperate with an Ever
larger and and moving Target of C plus
plus
um well the first step is is we have to
cheat a little bit so we don't need to
interoperate with with all possible C
plus plus we need to operate with real C
plus plus that exists in the world
that helps us a little bit though not a
lot because there's a lot of SQL Plus in
the world
so the other big thing that we're
relying on is we're going to build our
interoperability on top of an existing
compiler we're primarily targeting
playing although there's nothing there's
nothing necessary about playing in that
but the idea is that if you take a
working C plus plus compiler that has
support for these different features
then we can build interoperability on
top of that compiler and and reuse the
amazing amount of work that the client
Community does to kind of keep up with
the standards for our interoperability
story uh if we if we didn't do that I
don't think we could we could possibly
do this but that's that's the
fundamental idea is that we have to keep
up we have to keep every time new
features come in Decline and people
start using them we have to figure out
how to interoperate them and map them
effectively back into carbon to a
certain extent though if if C plus plus
is moving faster than we can move in
carbon then we've actually answered the
experimental question of carbon right
because then this isn't a more effective
Evolution process an evolution strategy
uh and so to a certain extent a core
thesis of this experiment is that we
think we can keep up with C plus plus uh
and and we'll learn we'll learn one way
or the other
uh one of the things that was mentioned
is that uh in C plus plus one of the
things that can hold it back is the
backwards compatibility and how would
that be administered in carbon would you
have different carbon aversions that
would not interoperate with one another
or would you also keep backwards
compatibility in a carbon
great question uh so the whole idea
around kind of language Evolution within
carbon is this idea of tool assisted
upgrades
uh and so we don't want to try and have
backwards compatibility in carbon we
think we'd end up exactly like facing
very similar in analogous technical
challenges at C plus spaces
instead we'd like to try and have tools
and both both in the language itself
language constructs and and actual tools
that developers can use to to handle the
incremental migration
uh so at the what we've observed is that
whenever you're updating from uh from an
old programming language version to a
new one uh at a certain scale if you
have enough code this is not a no-up
there's some breaking change because at
the very least you need a new version of
your compiler and and in our experience
every new version of the compiler some
small things have changed enough that
there is a cost we have to modify some
code in order to make those updates
and what we want to do is we want to try
and build tools and an Automation and
language features that just dramatically
scale up the kinds of changes that
people can afford to take when they're
ready to do an upgrade uh this is fairly
similar to Russ epochs if you're
familiar with them where they try or not
epocs anymore they're uh editions I
think okay which name they picked for
them but they they have they have
Milestones that they try and Target and
and you know when they're going to
upgrade and see like major and
significant changes to the language you
can plan for it there's a period of time
where you can kind of manage the
migration of your source code from the
old version to the new we think we can
give people these kinds of tools so that
they can actually do the upgrade and
they have enough interoperability
between versions to do the upgrade but
they are going to have to keep moving
because if we don't do that we don't get
to really solve these problems
okay I think that's it
that's it well thank all of you again so
much for having me uh especially from
the other side of the planet uh it's
been it's been a real pleasure to be
able to actually talk to you even a
little bit and and if you have more
questions or if you're interested in the
Projects please get on the GitHub join
the the Discord you can join the Discord
and ping me directly there or just ask
the community I'd love to have you and
I'd love to have more questions so thank
you again